the flash appeal for response inside
ukraine
which i'm responsible for coordinating
will need 1.1
billion dollars in funding for three
months
to help six million of the most
vulnerable in ukraine for that three
months and of those six million we
calculate
over a million
uh will be internally displaced
and i think the important point there is
that those in need are not only those
who move
but those in need will be those whose
basic services have been destroyed whose
pensions have been stopped whose
internet has been has been
stopped whose health care is is
necessary we'll provide health care food
sanitation shelter psychosocial
counselling in close collaboration with
our local partners
women and girls needs as always we see
in these situations must be specially
looked after and everybody's protection
insured last night at the security
council i reported
520 000 refugees
now less than 24 hours before the latest
figure i just got it is
677 000. so another 150 000 added in
less than 24 hours i would say about
half
of this i don't have the detailed
breakdown of the 677 but about half
are
in poland
this is the country that is clearly as
we predicted receiving most refugees
about 90 000 probably a little bit more
forgive me if the figures are a bit
fluid
i have gone to hungary
um
almost 60 000 to moldova
almost 50 000 to slovakia and almost or
i would say by now 40 000 in romania